dans le ciel de bourges on a présenté le
nord 3200 bon j'ai l'aérospatiale c'est
une histoire qui dure depuis près d'un
siècle
dix ans après la fin de la grande guerre
et les premiers exploits de l'aviation
militaire henri laudier à leur mère
décidé de construire une école de
pilotage
inaugurée le 1er juillet 1928 rené se
souvient c'était un grand jour pour au
bourget pour tout le monde parce que
c'était une inauguration de de
l'aérogare le premier qui sait qu'ils
existent et qui a été fait par commandé
par henri gaudier à l'instant c'est
réglé pilote d'essai c'est grâce à ces
deux personnes doit d'ailleurs que leur
club ont été formulées par la suite et
pour célébrer cet anniversaire rien de
tel qu'une pièce rare ce nord atlas
entièrement fabriquée à bourges entre
1949 et 1956 a fait tout spécialement le
déplacement de marignane un moment
d'émerveillement pour les jeunes pilotes
locaux lors sa magie quoi ça que c'était
l'avion c'est l'avion mythique a été
construit un beau cocktail temps c'est
vrai avoue grosse crise et beaucoup
d'avions et j'ai jamais pu voir en vrai
je sais qu'il y avait il ya dix ans un
meeting et moi j'ai pas pu avec 12 ans
j'étais pas là à ce moment là mais
l'aéroport de bourges c'est aussi un
tournant de l'économie locale il y a eu
des hauts des bas bien entendu il y a eu
beaucoup de travail dans l'aéronautique
est ensuite bien il ya eu des périodes
un peu plus difficiles et dans les
périodes difficiles sont arrivés des
choses que vous savez même pas comment
les appeler ça s'appelait les engins ça
va devenir les missiles et l'usiné va
devenir une usine avions et missiles
mais progressivement une usine missiles
d'autres présentations d'avions modernes
et anciens sont prévus pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir toute l'histoire de cet
aéroport les visiteurs sont les
bienvenus ce dimanche
[Musique]